We've arrived at the final tool for
this course, the debug view hierarchy.
This was recently added to Xcode, and
it allows us to dig in to the visual
hierarchy of an app
while we're debugging.
So to make things interesting,
let's run the application, and
I'm going to create a couple spiders.
[SOUND] There we go.
And let's set a breakpoint in the add
bug to view, and jump back and
drop into our breakpoint.
From here, there are two ways to
access the debug view hierarchy.
The first is in the debug navigator, and
we get to it by going to
the debug navigator, and
then selecting this UI hierarchy from
the dropdown, from this icon here.
So we'll select it.
And if we look at this unfolded list,
we can see all the different UI
image views, debugs,
essentially that are being created.
And we can see where they're located.
If we click on one of the items in the
list, this is where it gets interesting.
It brings us to this visual
display of our view.
So as I'm selecting on these,
these are debugs that I click on.
This.
It's talking about
the buttons that we have.
And there are debugs.
Now if we click and drag this area,
this is really cool.
It explodes into a three dimensional
view of our view hierarchy.
And we can see visually now.
Some of the relationships between
different elements in the view.
Just like the list, we can select
the different components, so
I'll select this one.
That's the UI Navigation
Transition View.
Select that one.
Let me zoom out just a tad.
There we go.
That's one of the UI image views.
There's a UI image view.
That's the UI navigation bar background,
and so on.
Now let's go over to the controls
that are available to us.
Dragging this bar in the lower left hand
corner, will allow us to increase and
decrease the spacing between
the components in the hierarchy.
The next two buttons can toggle,
showing clipped contents, and
constraints, which does not do much for
us here.
Let's just leave it as is.
And, the third button from the left,
can flatten the view back into
its two dimensional form.
Next are the viewing modes which include
contents, wireframes, and wireframes and
contents.
And let's just leave it as wireframe and
contents for now.
After that, we have these minus and
plus icons which are for zooming.
And then if we click the equal
sign it will just zoom, so
that maximizes your view based on
the space that's available to you.
Now this last control.
What it does is, it adjust the views
that are visible from you going from
the bottom most views on the left,
to the top most views on the right.
So, if I start by dragging from
the right, and moving left, you should
see the things on the top disappear,
before the things on the bottom do.
And, hold up.
Let me zoom out.
There we go.
And let me tilt it a little bit.
And those are all the controls
that we have on the bottom.
The next thing that we can do in the
debug view hierarchy, is get diagnostic
information about the components
we've selected in the utility area.
So you'll want to click
one of the components.
And then to display the utility area,
make sure that you've
toggled on this icon here.
There we go.
And here you can see information
about the component's type.
UI image view, it's raw address.
Some state information.
And a display showing its content.
The raw address, hint,
hint, can be casted like we did
earlier in the command line interface,
to gather more information
about the component itself.
So you can see how this would be
incredibly useful, especially for
games and other applications.
A lot of things going in and
out of the view.
This is a really cool way
to debug our application.